prior to the release of Indiana Jones
and the dial of Destiny there was a lot
of talk about how the film would use the
Aging technology for the sequence at the
beginning of the film set during World
War II the goal was to make Indiana
Jones look similar to how he did in
Raiders of the Lost Ark and the digital
effect was mostly a success while
there's ample CGI on display throughout
the rest of the movie there are also
good old-fashioned practical effects
including a realistic mask that may just
haunt your dreams on Instagram special
effects artist Waldo Mason shared images
of a stunt mask used in dial of Destiny
while the realistic skin texture makes
the mask somewhat uncanny on its own it
doesn't seem all that freaky but it's a
different story when we see it in action
Mason included two pictures of a stunt
double wearing the mask on top of
motorcycle and standing in an office the
use of stun doubles with prosthetics is
nothing new for action movies but out of
context the mask is definitely getting a
strong reaction from Indiana Jones fans